and I think this does actually point a
way forward in the science of
Consciousness a way of avoiding some of
the deep perennial difficulties we've
had in the science of consciousness
[Music]
Philip Goff welcome to how the light
gets in thank you very much it's great
to be here I'm having a lovely time what
first got you interested in philosophy I
know this is a very broad question but
something always triggers one's interest
what was it for you yeah I think I've
just always been obsessed with
philosophy as far back as I remember
really I think my parents tell me that
when I was four I asked why are we here
but we had just moved house so I think I
was just maybe confused about the
location but yeah I guess always been
interested in how everything fits
together you know I was raised Catholic
and I remember asking the priest
how Adam and Eve fit together with the
big bang you know what happened to Adam
and Eve when the big bang you know so I
was hearing these different stories and
trying to fit everything together so I
think that's always been my
philosophical interest how do we have a
a world view that can accommodate all
the different things we know to be real
and that gets them really driven always
really been driven by that so a little
bit like Wilfred sellers there's
definition of philosophy seeing how
everything hangs together in the broader
sense of of yeah absolutely yeah
thinking
you know maybe maybe if you just think
the only way we find out about the world
is experiments public observation
experiments then maybe there isn't such
of a a role for philosophy in this world
view construction but I'm inclined to
think
that actually we we know things about
reality in other ways for example
through our immediate awareness of our
own feelings and experiences you know I
think Consciousness isn't something we
discovered in a particle collider it's
not something we know about for
observation and experiments but through
our immediate awareness of our feelings
and experiences also I think another
example mathematical entities the
Timeless entities of numbers and sets
and functions you know we didn't
discover these looking through
microscopes we discern their existence
through mathematical intuition so I
guess I'm inclined to think there are
these different kinds of entities we
know about in different ways and so then
there's a task for philosophy to bring
it all together to take the things we
know about through experimental science
to take also the things we know about in
different ways and to synthesize it all
together in a grand unified theory of
reality you mentioned Consciousness
there as something that uh philosophy
kind of studies it's not something that
we discover empirically in the world
something we know from the first person
perspective what is consciousness how do
you define it yeah it's a good question
because it is a little bit of an
ambiguous word that's often defined in
different ways some often people use the
word Consciousness to mean something
quite cognitively sophisticated like
awareness of One's Own existence but the
way it's generally used in philosophy
and the way I use it is just to mean
subjective experience what it's like to
be you so right now you're having an
auditory experience of my voice speaking
to you
a visual experience of the tent around
you you know if you pay attention
there's the subtle tactile sensations of
the chair beneath your body this is all
part of what it's like to be you right
now and that's just what we mean by
consciousness
one of your books is entitled Galileo's
error foundations for a new science of
Consciousness
and here we have even in the title a
kind of collision between science and
the kind of Revolution that Galileo
brought into science and a different
kind of science that hasn't maybe been
born yet the science of Consciousness
what was Galileo's error in your mind
and why is that been a problem for
accommodating Consciousness into the
natural world
yeah so I mean it's a provocative title
I suppose I mean I'm actually a huge fan
of Galileo and I think he understood
these issues a lot better than many many
scientists do now but so I think well a
key moment in the Scientific Revolution
was Galileo's declaration that
mathematics was to be the language of
the new science the new science was to
have this purely quantitative vocabulary
uh now although this is much discussed
what's what's often neglected is the
philosophical work Galileo had to do to
get to that we think of Galileo as a
great experimental scientist which of
course he was but he was also a great
philosopher and he he really designed
the philosophy that underlay the
Scientific Revolution so the problem for
Galileo was
the world seemed to be filled with these
qualities
your colors on the surfaces of objects
it's smells floating through the air
tastes inside food
and it doesn't seem like we can capture
these kinds of qualities in the purely
quantitative language of mathematics you
know an equation can't capture that deep
red you experience as you watch the
Setting Sun so this is a problem for
Galileo he wanted science to be totally
quantitative totally mathematical what
are we going to do with these qualities
so Galileo got around this by proposing
a radically new philosophical theory of
reality and and according to that theory
the qualities aren't really out there in
the physical world
they're in the consciousness of the
Observer so the the yellow on this
sunflower isn't really on the surface of
the sunflower up the surface of the
petal it's in the consciousness of the
person observing it
which then Galileo took to be outside of
science so Galileo really strips the
what the physical world of its qualities
says they're in there in Consciousness
that's outside of the domain of science
once we've done that
we can capture everything else in
mathematics in this purely quantitative
language so that's the start of
mathematical physics and that's gone
incredibly well
I think it's gone so well that we're now
going for a phase of History where
people think
that's the total truth that's the that's
the complete truth about reality the eye
really is it's gone so well precisely
because it was designed to be a partial
description of reality one which sets
Consciousness outside of the domain of
science so that's why we have a problem
of Consciousness
um because Galileo separated out the
purely quantitative domain of science
from the qualitative domain of
Consciousness I think if we want to
solve the problem of Consciousness we
need to find a way of bringing these two
domains back together
so as you as you were saying Galileo
sort of goes on to describe nature and
these kind of mathematical terms and
Consciousness sort of falls out of
nature it falls out of kind of the
description of the Natural Sciences and
we now are faced with the problem of
trying to bring the two back together
and the solutions proposed so far you
know dualism or physicalism seem to
be facing various dead ends and you have
a different proposal you you offer this
alternative to the solution to the
problem of placing Consciousness within
nature which is uh pan psychism
can you tell us what pan psychism is and
how does it solve the problem of
locating Consciousness within nature so
in in our
way of thinking about these things
Consciousness exists
only in the brains of Highly evolved
organisms and so only exists in really a
tiny part of the universe and only in
very recent history
cosmically speaking at least but
according to pan psyches and
Consciousness pervades the universe and
is a fundamental feature of it so it
doesn't literally mean everything is
conscious despite the the etymology of
the word pan psychism literally means
everything has mind
but the in contemporary forms upon
cycles and the basic commitment is that
the the fundamental building blocks of
the physical Universe perhaps
fundamental particles like electrons and
quarks have unimaginably simple forms of
experience and that the very complex
experience of of the human or animal
brain is somehow built up from the very
simple experience of the of the brain's
most basic parts
so I guess it I mean in a way you can
see it as an alternative research
program we've been
trying for many decades now to explain
Consciousness in terms of utterly
non-conscious processes in the brain and
got precisely nowhere in my view I mean
we've done lots of cool stuff for the
signs of Consciousness but in terms of
that difficulty of reductively
explaining Consciousness I would say
we've got nowhere here's an alternative
program rather than explaining
Consciousness in terms of
non-consciousness
explain complex forms of Consciousness
in terms of simpler forms of
Consciousness where those simpler forms
of Consciousness are then postulated to
exist as basic aspects of matter earlier
on you define consciousness as it being
something to be like an entity right
this is goes back to kind of Thomas
Nagel's definition of Consciousness so
it's something to be a human being and
something to be me it's something to be
about as Nagel said does pan psychism
claim that it is something to be a table
or that there is something that it is
like to be an atom or an electron or an
iPhone is that is that the idea yeah
just on on the phrase what it's like to
be actually it was used by the great pan
psychist Timothy Sprigg before Nagel I
always feel he's a bit neglected
although probably to be fair Nagle was
the first to explicitly Define
consciousness using that phrase although
sprig did use it earlier yeah so
pancyclists needn't think everything is
conscious they think the basic building
blocks of reality are conscious may be
let's say fundamental particles but they
needn't think every random combination
of particles is conscious they needn't
think rocks and socks and tables and
chairs are conscious so pansakis might
not think this chair is conscious
they'll just think it's made up of
little particles that are themselves
conscious in some very rudimentary sense
um but this is a matter of some
controversy you know some philosophers
some pan psychists like Luke roloffs
think literally everything is conscious
the chair the table my nose
but even then
he wouldn't think that the chair has the
kind of Consciousness I have the chair
is not sitting there thinking I wish
he'd stop sitting on me you know our
Consciousness is what you get after
millions of years of evolution by
natural selection you get intelligence
you get agency uh the consciousness of
the chair would be
of a totally meaningless non-agentive
non-intelligent character
so that's what sometimes I just think I
guess I'm more inclined to think that
the conditions under which
simple conscious things combined
together to make complex conscious
things are quite rare and that natural
selection as it were discovered this and
exploited it so probably consciousness
pervades the biological realm the level
of cells and molecules
but outside of the biological realm
perhaps it's it's more or less confined
to the to the level of basic physics so
something that struck me when you were
describing now the way that pan
psychists argue that well not everything
is has Consciousness it's the it's the
building blocks that have Consciousness
the building blocks of reality the
fundamental particles perhaps I was
wondering whether you're introducing a
different kind of problem of
Consciousness from the one that we have
so at the moment our problem is well how
do you get conscious beings from
unconscious stuff non-conscious stuff if
matter is unconscious what is it about
this configuration of matter in the
brain and the humans and animals and so
on that creates Consciousness does pan
psychism create the opposite problem of
how do you end up with non-conscious
entities like chairs if the building
blocks are fundamentally conscious
that's interesting so I thought you were
going to give the the more classic
objection to pan psychism that the
combination problem how do we get little
conscious things coming together to make
big conscious things like brains that's
often called pan psychism's hard problem
but actually you've given a a different
thought there why why is consciousness
not more widespread than even pansakers
take it to be well maybe
to answer your question we we probably
would need first to address the the much
discussed combination problem this
challenge of how
little conscious things combined
together to make big conscious things
and so broadly speaking there there are
two options here which I sometimes call
weak emergentism and strong emergentism
so the weak emergent as pan psychist
is very much a reductionist it's very
similar to materialism in a way for the
weak emergentist
once you've got conscious particles
arranged in the right way you've got a
conscious brain it's a little bit like
for the weak emergent is the
relationship between a conscious brain
and conscious particles is a little bit
like the relationship between
a party and the people dancing and
drinking you know once you've got people
dancing and drinking you've got a party
that's all it is for there to be a party
is for there to be people dancing and
drinking for the weak emergent is pan
psychist
all it is for there to be a conscious
brain
is to have is for there to be conscious
particles arranged in the right way so
again Luke roloffs has in his book
combining Minds has tried to make sense
of this I'm more skeptical of that
strongly reductionist position I think
you are going to have similar kind of
explanatory gaps
that you find in materialism so the
classic explanatory Gap in materialism
is how you get from the quantitative
story of Neuroscience of the physical
processes in the brain to the qualities
we find in Consciousness the colors The
Sounds the smells the tastes but I think
the reductionist weak emergent is
pansychist is going to face similar
expansory gaps how do you get from facts
about conscious particles to facts about
a conscious brain I'm more attracted to
what's sometimes called strong emergent
is psychism that actually new
fundamental entities and forms of
Consciousness emerge at the
neurophysiological level now they don't
pop up out of nowhere typically the
strong emergentists will think that
they're brought into being by the
interactions of conscious particles
nonetheless
these new forms of Consciousness are
fundamental in their own right so maybe
a good analogy is you know what the
interactions of my parents produced me
but I'm obviously distinct from extra to
my parents similarly for the strong
emergent is pansychist the human
conscious mind is brought into being and
sustained in existence by interactions
of conscious particles nonetheless the
human conscious mind is distinct from an
extra to the conscious particles that
sustain its existence
um so I used to think there were
empirical problems with the um
with strong emergent disposition I used
to think
um I used to adopt the thesis that's
sometimes called the causal closure of
the physical but everything that
everything that happens in the brain can
be reduced to underlying chemistry and
physics that would seem to rule out the
strong emergent disposition which says
there are these new properties new
entities of the neurophysiological level
but actually the more I talk to
neuroscientists and read neuroscience
I really don't think we're at a stage
where we know enough about the brain to
know one way or another I think strong
emergentism is just an open empirical
question it's an open question
empirically and on philosophical grounds
I'm more and more inclined to go in that
direction to Circle back to an early
topic we discussed uh the relationship
between philosophy and science is their
way of testing pentakism empirically and
if so how we would we go about doing
that
or is this a kind of philosophical
theory that is distinct from empirical
testing and it is more about just making
sense of the world given everything we
know about it given the physical
theories we know are given the fact that
we know Consciousness is a phenomenon
that we have access to is that just
kind of inference the best explanation
as it were or is it something that can
be tested
so there's there's a deep problem at the
heart of Consciousness science
and that is that Consciousness is not
publicly observable you can't look
inside somebody's head and see their
feelings and experiences we know about
Consciousness not from observation and
experiment but from our immediate
awareness of our feelings and
experiences if you're in pain you're
just directly aware of your pain
now people then say Oh but science deals
with unobservables all the time
fundamental particles can't be directly
observed but there's an important
difference here
in all other cases
we postulate unobservables
to explain what we can observe
in the unique case of Consciousness the
thing we are trying to explain is
unobservable
and this really I think constrains our
capacity to deal with it experimentally
now of course we can deal with it
experimentally there is a robust and
well-developed signs of consciousness
how does that work
well I think although you can't observe
someone's Consciousness you can ask them
what they're feeling and experiencing
and if you do that while you scan their
brains then we can start to establish
correlations between
certain kinds of brain activity and
certain kinds of conscious experience
and that's really important data
but that is not in itself a theory of
Consciousness what we ultimately want
from a theory of consciousness
is an explanation of why
why
certain kinds of brain activity are
correlated with certain kinds of
experience and because Consciousness is
not publicly observable
I don't think that's a question you can
answer experimentally I think at that
point you've got to turn to philosophy
and just look at the various options
that philosophers have offered
to explain why brain activity goes along
with Consciousness so materialism pan
psychism dualism idealism
um I mean I say it's philosophy I hope
one day it will be established science
the subtitle of my book Galileo's era is
foundations for a new science of
Consciousness you know philosophy is
what you get when the rules of the game
are not settled I hope one day this will
be established science but at the moment
it's still in the realm of um
of philosophy essentially you say that
in the future maybe there will be a
signs of Consciousness and possibly
therefore we will be able to to test a
hypothesis like pan psychism how do you
see the kind of disability of that
working out what one thing I'm in been
thinking a lot about at the moment is my
increasing attraction to this the strong
emergentist view that there are new
entities and properties at the
neurophysiological level
if that turns out to be the case then I
think this does actually point a way
forward in the science of Consciousness
a way of avoiding some of the deep
perennial difficulties we've had in the
science of Consciousness so towards the
end of the 1990s the neuroscientist
Christoph Coke that David Chalmers a
crate of fine wine that we were within
25 years we'd have the complete neural
correlative consciousness it's looking
like he's about to lose that bet because
you know the time's nearly up and we've
got multiple different theories with
very different claims about where the
neural correlates of Consciousness is
and seemingly no way of establishing
consensus and I think this is because
Consciousness is not publicly observable
um so we've got so for example because
to do signs of Consciousness we have to
establish
what I call detection procedures
principles which link
observable data to unobservable
Consciousness for example we have what I
call the report principle which is the
principle that if somebody is having a
conscious experience they're able to
report it
so if you adapt if you adopt that
principle you can start to do
Consciousness science because you can
just ask someone and if they say I'm not
experiencing this then they're not
experiencing it but the trouble is all
these principles are controversial so
someone like Ned block for example
adopts what has become known as the
Overflow thesis that there are
experiences we are having but that we
can't attend to so why would you think
that
um
it's pretty well established now that
there are significant limits on what
we're able to attend to at one time so I
can't attend to all the details of your
face and all the sounds outside and the
feeling of my clothes on my body
so there are limits to how much we can
attend to at once and then there's two
ways you can go with that you can either
say
well actually Consciousness is very
sparse the only things we're really
experience are those we can attend to
alternatively people like Ned block say
no actually Consciousness is incredibly
rich I am actually experiencing the
intricate details of your face the Sound
Outside the feel of the clothes on my
body it's just I'm limited in what I can
attend to and if you have that kind of
break between
tension and Consciousness are what's
sometimes called access Consciousness
and phenomenal Consciousness then you're
likely to deny the report principle
you're likely to think people could be
having experiences even though they
can't report on them so this might sound
like an abstract debate but it leads to
very different theories of Consciousness
scientific theories of Consciousness so
if you think Consciousness is very
closely related to attention you're more
likely to think Consciousness is in the
front of the brain where the prefrontal
cortex is because that's closely
connected to cognitive functions like
working memory but if if you think there
is this break between attention and
Consciousness you're likely to think
Consciousness is at the back of the
brain so how do we move forward with
this well if strong emergence turns out
to be the case which I'm inclined to
think it is
this could point A Way Forward because
if it turns out for example that there
is stronger that turns out to be strong
emergent Dynamics at the back of the
brain rather than the front there are
causal dynamics that are not reducible
to underlying chemistry and physics that
would strongly support the hypothesis
the Consciousness is at the back rather
than the front of the brain and this
isn't just an abstract possibility there
are for example Martin Picard who runs
the mitochondrial psychobiology lab in
Columbia University is exploring
experimentally the hypothesis that
mitochondria in the brain form social
networks and that rather than reducing
mitochondria to underlying chemistry and
physics we should understand them as
irreducible social networks or the
neuroscientist Kevin Mitchell who's not
at all a fan of pansychism but he is
inclined to think there are strongly
emergent Dynamics in the brain and is
exploring interesting ways of trying to
model that so these seem to me the most
exciting way forwards on assigned to
Consciousness I mean I don't think
you'll ever pin down every all aspects
of a theory of Consciousness with
experiments because Consciousness is not
publicly observable so I think here's a
prediction I think at some point strong
emergentism
will be empirically demonstrated and I
think at that point you've got two
options you either go for the David
Chalmers naturalistic duelist type
position that Consciousness is strongly
emerging from totally non-physical brain
processes or you go the pansychist
option that complex Consciousness is
strongly emerging from simpler forms of
consciousness
so it could be that experiments can't
distinguish those two options but I
think in that case there's a strong
Simplicity based uh reason to go for the
pan psychist option you know as
scientists and philosophers we try to
find the most simple unified theory of
reality
hansikis believe in one kind of
fundamental property Duelists believe in
two so here's my bet
in 50 years time I'll bet you a case of
wine that's good strong imaginism will
be proved to be true and we'll be left
with a choice between Chalmers dualism
and my pan psychism and because
pansychism is just a simpler option it
will just come to see him over time or
just come to seem obviously true
we'll have to get you back in
2071 and uh hold you up to that list
Phillip Goff thank you very much thank
you lovely chatting
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute arts
and ideas at IAI TV
[Music]